Transcription: Mandy Vincent
Relecteur: eric vautier
« Des chercheurs qui cherchent,
on en trouve.
Mais des chercheurs qui trouvent,
on en cherche. »
Vous connaissez peut-être
cette vieille plaisanterie,
mais qui illustre assez bien le décalage
entre les chercheurs et
les scientifiques d’une part,
et le grand public.
D’après une étude de 2020,
un Français sur deux ne comprend pas
comment les chercheurs
travaillent au quotidien,
ne comprend pas
les résultats de la recherche,
ni les enjeux pour la société.
Et pourtant, à la question :
« Avez-vous confiance en la science ? »,
une large majorité répond oui.
Alors, mon métier,
c’est chercheur.
D’après ces chiffres,
ce soir, dans cette salle,
une moitié d’entre vous se
demande pourquoi je cherche
et l’autre moitié n’est pas tout
à fait sûre de ce que je trouve.
Alors pourquoi ?
Pourquoi ce malentendu entre nous ?
D’abord, à cause d’un problème,
la barrière de la langue.
Parce que les chercheurs
ont un langage à part.
Je m’en suis rendu compte étant étudiant.
À l’époque, je finis ma première
année de doctorat au CNRS
et un matin, mon directeur
vient me voir dans mon bureau.
Il me dit :
« J’ai une proposition à te faire,
j’ai besoin de quelqu’un
pour un projet un peu spécial. »
Or, je savais qu’il préparait
une expédition scientifique en Chine
et j’aurais littéralement
tué pour y participer.
Je lui dis : « Professeur,
je prends, pas de problème. »
Et je me suis retrouvé
guide de grottes en Ariège,
en face du laboratoire,
les soirs et les week-ends.
(Rires)
Car notre laboratoire était spécialisé
dans l’étude des milieux souterrains
et juste en face, à 200 mètres,
on avait une grotte,
aménagée pour faire de la recherche,
que le directeur voulait ouvrir au public.
C’est-à-dire qu’on m’a demandé
d’expliquer nos recherches,
mais pas à des scientifiques,
à des gens.
A des enfants, des scolaires,
des étudiants, à des journalistes,
à des touristes, à des curieux,
à des amoureux de la science.
Le clou de la visite était
notre élevage de protées.
Le protée est un animal très particulier
qui vit dans les grottes.
En l’occurrence,
c’était mon sujet de recherche.
J’avais préparé une présentation
tout public qui donnait à peu près ceci :
« Le protée - Proteus anguinus -
est un amphibien, urodèle, stygobie,
inféodé aux écosystèmes karstiques
souterrains de la zone dinarique,
dont les capacités chémoréceptrices
hors du commun
relèvent d’une meilleure intégration
comportementale
des stimuli physico-chimiques
environnementaux
qu’une hypertrophie morpho-fonctionnelle
de l’épithélium olfactif
dont la structure pseudostratifiée
ne présente pas
de différences anatomiques majeures
au niveau cellulaire ou subcellulaire
avec celles d’autres modèles
amphibiens taxonomiquement proches.
Des questions ? »
(Applaudissements)
Vous imaginez le succès
avec les classes de CP.
(Rires)
Et c’est là que j’ai réalisé
que faire de la recherche
et expliquer la recherche
sont deux choses très différentes
à cause du langage.
Le métier d’un chercheur,
c’est de faire progresser la connaissance
en partageant l’avancée de ses travaux
avec d’autres chercheurs sous forme
d’articles, de conférences scientifiques.
Ce sont des textes que vous
ne trouverez pas en librairie
parce qu’ils sont publiés
dans des revues spécialisées
écrites par des chercheurs,
pour des chercheurs
et donc, avec un style,
un formalisme, très strict
et l’utilisation d’un langage complexe
propre à chaque discipline.
Le fameux jargon.
Ce soir, entre nous, qui a déjà
lu un article scientifique ?
Jusqu’au bout ?
(Rires)
Un article, jusqu’à quel point
est-ce compréhensible ?
Pour y répondre, des chercheurs
en linguistique de l’université d’Haïfa,
ont développé un programme
qui permet d’évaluer
le niveau de compréhension d’un texte
à partir de l’analyse des mots employés.
Ils l’ont appelé le « déjargoniseur ».
Prenons, par exemple, cet article publié
récemment par un de mes étudiants
et qui traite de l’adaptation
au changement climatique.
Après passage au déjargoniseur,
voilà ce qu’on obtient.
En rouge, c’est le jargon,
les mots réservés aux spécialistes.
15% du texte.
En orange, le vocabulaire intermédiaire,
c’est-à-dire normalement accessible à
des lecteurs de niveau moyen ou avancé.
20 % du texte.
Et le reste en noir, le langage courant.
D’après vous, quel est le niveau
maximum de jargon acceptable
si on veut vraiment comprendre un texte ?
(Le public répond)
Non, nettement moins 2 à 3%.
La réalité est que les seules personnes
qui comprennent vraiment ces articles,
ce sont les chercheurs qui les écrivent
et leurs collègues de la même discipline.
Pourrait-on faire autrement ?
Reprenons mon exemple du protée
et remplaçons les termes scientifiques
par leur définition courante.
Le protée est un amphibien,
c’est-à-dire, je cite le Larousse,
un vertébré anamniote, à peau nue,
aux membres conformés en pattes,
capable de respirer
hors de l’eau à l’état adulte.
Anamniote, c’est-à-dire dépourvu d’amnios,
la plus interne des couches du fœtus.
Urodèle, c’est-à-dire
qu’il a un corps allongé,
quatre pattes, une longue queue
comme les tritons et les salamandres.
Stygobie est un terme de biospéléologie
et ça désigne les animaux qui passent
la totalité de leur cycle vital
dans les eaux souterraines.
Strictement inféodé,
c’est-à-dire indissociablement lié d’un
point de vue écologique aux écosystèmes,
l'ensemble des organismes vivants en
interaction mutuelle au sein d'un habitat.
Karstique, mot d’origine slave
qui désigne ce type de paysage formé
par la dissolution des roches carbonatées,
autrement dit des roches calcaires
formées à plus de 50 % de carbonates,
donc, des calcaires.
Souterrain ?
(Rires)
Vous vous souvenez ?
C'était juste la première phrase.
En fait, si le langage
de la science était un art,
ce serait celui de l’origami,
où chaque mot porte en lui-même
tout un univers de savoirs en miniature,
condensé, codifié et qui se déplie
uniquement pour les initiés.
Le langage scientifique,
c’est l’art de dire beaucoup avec peu.
Et de le dire avec précision,
c’est-à-dire avec efficacité.
Ce qui explique au passage pourquoi
les chercheurs sont assez mal à l’aise
avec le langage courant.
Beaucoup trop simple, trop facile.
Pour nous aider, Charles,
notre informaticien,
a développé une application
de reconnaissance vocale
qui permet de transcrire
le vocabulaire courant
sous une forme plus
adaptée aux chercheurs.
Prenons un exemple au hasard.
Un agneau se désaltérait
dans le courant d’une onde pure.
Un loup survint à jeun
qui cherchait aventure
et que la faim en ces lieux attirait.
[Compétition inter-espèces.
Loup (Canis lupus)
vs. agneau (Ovis aries)]
Vous voyez, pour nous,
c’est bien, c’est clair,
c’est précis, c’est compréhensible.
C'est beau.
Merci Charles.
(Rires)
Et d'ailleurs, on évite aussi un certain
nombre de malentendus au quotidien.
Par exemple, en société.
Bonsoir, Mademoiselle.
Allons voir si la rose
qui ce matin avait déclose
Sa robe de pourpre au soleil
A point perdu cette vesprée.
Les plis de sa robe pourprée
et son teint au vôtre pareil.
[Viens voir le rosier (Rosa gallica)]
(Rires et applaudissements)
Alors,
on perd un peu les nuances.
(Rires)
En science, comme en poésie,
simplifier, ce n’est pas uniquement
remplacer les termes compliqués.
Peu de temps après ma thèse,
je suis recruté comme chercheur
en écologie des systèmes
aquatiques continentaux
et je pars en Guyane
travailler sur les mangroves.
Je commençais mon nouveau programme
de recherche, quand, un matin,
mon directeur vient me voir
dans mon bureau et me dit :
« J’ai une proposition à te faire.
J’ai besoin de quelqu’un
pour un projet un peu spécial. »
Cette fois, je me suis retrouvé
conférencier de La Pirogue des Sciences.
J’allais remonter
le fleuve Maroni en pirogue
sur plusieurs jours
jusqu’en territoire amérindien,
où on avait organisé une série de
conférences dans les écoles primaires
et j’allais leur parler de mes recherches,
c’est-à-dire du cycle
de vie des crevettes.
J’essayais de comprendre
pourquoi, en Guyane,
les crevettes disparaissent des mangroves
plusieurs heures par jour, tous les jours,
alors que normalement,
c’est le refuge contre les prédateurs.
Comment expliquer des idées complexes
mais de façon simple mais pas simpliste ?
A votre avis, est-ce que
c’est une question de contenu ?
Alors, faisons ensemble un petit test.
Vous allez voir une série de lettres
et je vais vous laisser quelques secondes
pour essayer de les mémoriser.
Prêts ?
C’est parti.
(Des lettres s’affichent à l’écran)
Oups.
(Rires)
Qui pourrait me les réciter sans erreur ?
C'est pourtant évident.
Alors, simplifions l’exercice.
Cette fois-ci, je vais changer juste
la façon dont je vous donne l’information.
Attention, c’est reparti.
[CAILLOUX BIJOUX GENOUX]
D’où vient la différence ?
Ce sont les mêmes lettres.
Mais cette fois-ci,
l’information est structurée,
elle est scindée en
sous-parties de petites tailles,
indépendantes, plus faciles à traiter.
Ensuite, l’information a du sens,
vous pouvez la relier à des
connaissances que vous avez déjà.
En l’occurrence, ici,
la fameuse liste des mots en x :
hiboux, choux, cailloux, genoux, poux
qu’on a tous apprise à l’école.
Enfin, cette information est efficace
parce qu’on a enlevé
tous les éléments superflus,
les couleurs, les tailles, les animations
qui viennent gêner le travail du cerveau.
Les neurosciences nous apprennent
que la façon dont on apprend
quelque chose, dont on l’explique -
donc la forme -
peut absolument tout changer,
indépendamment du fond,
c’est-à-dire du contenu.
Paradoxalement, expliquer la science,
ce n’est pas uniquement
une question de sciences
c’est aussi une question de communication.
Or, par défaut,
les chercheurs ont un registre de
communication assez restreint, limité
parce qu’il est basé
sur la logique, la raison.
Et en plus, cette logique
ne saute pas toujours aux yeux.
Prenons l’exemple des noms
scientifiques des espèces.
Vous n’êtes pas sans savoir que de
nos jours plus personne ne parle latin
sauf au Vatican.
Et pourtant, en 2022, on continue
d’attribuer un double nom latin
ou pseudo-latin, à chaque
espèce nouvellement décrite.
Pourquoi ?
A la fin du XVIIᵉ siècle, les naturalistes
sont confrontés à un nouveau problème.
Ils n’ont plus de noms pour décrire
toutes ces nouvelles espèces
qui arrivent par bateau
des expéditions de découverte
d’Asie, d’Afrique ou des Amériques.
À l’époque, on ne donne pas
forcément un nom à chaque espèce
parce que personne n’est vraiment
d’accord sur la façon de les classer.
Et c’est pour organiser ce vaste chaos
que Carl von Linné, un biologiste suédois,
va progressivement généraliser
un système plus simple,
basé sur deux principes.
Chaque espèce recevra
un nom systématiquement
et un nom unique,
pour éviter les confusions avec d’autres.
Et ce nom sera composé de deux parties,
un nom de genre et un nom d’espèce.
Imaginez un tiroir dans lequel vous allez
pouvoir regrouper les espèces apparentées.
Qui choisit ou qui invente ce nom ?
C’est le premier qui décrit
officiellement l’espèce,
publication à l’appui.
Il y a un certain nombre de règles.
La principale, c’est de latiniser
les noms scientifiques,
quelle que soit la langue d’origine
des mots utilisés pour les créer.
En général, on choisit
des noms qui vont renseigner
sur une caractéristique de l’espèce :
sa taille, sa forme, sa couleur,
l’endroit de sa découverte,
ou qui sont donnés
[en hommage] à quelqu’un.
En résumé, les noms scientifiques
sont des noms de code
dont la clé est dans une langue morte.
Exemple, « Myrmecophaga tridactyla »
du grec « myrmeco », « fourmi »
et « phágos », « mangeur »,
« le mangeur de fourmis ».
Et « tridactyla »
du latin « tri », « trois »,
« dactylus » « doigt »,
« à trois doigts ».
« Le mangeur de fourmis à trois doigts ».
Le fourmilier.
Un autre.
« Echinoprocta rufescens »
de « ekhînos », « épines »
et « prôktós », « anus » -
comme dans proctologue -
« Qui a des épines autour de l’anus ».
Et « rufescens » en latin, « rougeâtre »,
« Qui a des épines autour de l’anus
et qui est rougeâtre ».
Le...
Le porc-épic rougeâtre.
C’était pourtant évident.
(Rires)
Le latin des naturalistes n’est pas
tout à fait celui de Cicéron.
Dans la pratique, vous pouvez inventer
quasiment n’importe quel nom,
tant qu’il sonne latin.
C’est un peu comme une loterie.
[Vini vidivici]
Un perroquet fossile.
[Abra cadabra]
Une palourde.
[Pliotoxaster donaldtrumpi]
Un oursin républicain.
(Rires)
[Polemistus chewbacca]
Une guêpe particulièrement poilue.
[Polemistus yoda]
et ses cousines.
[Polemistus vaderi]
La force est puissante dans la famille.
Et celle dont on ne sait pas
prononcer le nom.
[Myxococcus llanfairpwll...]
Une bactérie qui a eu
la malchance d’être découverte
dans le petit village gallois
qui lui a donné son nom.
Je précise, ce sont tous des noms
strictement authentiques.
À ce stade, j’imagine que
vous vous demandez pourquoi
on continue à utiliser
un système aussi archaïque.
Pourquoi ne pas appeler un chat,
un chat plutôt que « Felis catus » ?
Prenons un exemple plus concret.
Le loup.
Le loup est un mammifère qui était chassé
en France jusqu’au début du XXᵉ siècle.
Mais si vous allez près des côtes
de la Manche, le loup, on le pêche
parce que c’est un poisson.
À ne pas confondre avec le loup de mer
qui est le nom du requin-renard,
qu’on appelle aussi singe de mer.
Mais si vous allez dans le sud,
le loup, c’est le bar.
À Arcachon, on l’appelle
« Loubine » ou « Louvine »
et les Bretons « Drenek ».
À Marseille, il ne faudrait pas
confondre le bar avec le sar
qu’on appelle « sar », « sargou »,
« saragou », « asparaillou »
ou « mouré punchu » -
le « museau pointu ».
Et là, on reste en France.
(Rires)
Maintenant, parlez du requin-renard
avec un pêcheur anglais,
« the fox shark ».
Avec un Espagnol « El zorro blanco »,
un Italien « La volpe di mare »,
un Allemand « der Drescherhaien »,
un Croate « Lisica »,
« Kalb » au Maroc,
« Pating » aux Philippines,
« Mao-naga » au Japon,
« Mangō-ripi » en Nouvelle-Zélande,
« Ma’o aero » en Polynésie,
(le mot en hindi) et
« Fynstert-sambokhaai » en Afrique du Sud.
(Applaudissements)
Ou on utilise le nom scientifique
unique « Alopias vulpinus »
et tout le monde sait exactement
de quoi on parle.
Vous voyez un peu mieux,
vous comprenez à quoi servent
les noms scientifiques.
Et pourtant, si on y réfléchit bien,
je ne vous ai pas vraiment expliqué.
En tout cas, pas de façon
scientifique traditionnelle.
Si on revenait ensemble
au début de cette conférence,
vous verriez qu’à la place d’expliquer,
j’ai surtout raconté.
Raconter,
c’est-à-dire contextualiser
des notions scientifiques
en faisant appel à votre imagination,
à votre vécu,
à vos références personnelles,
et à vos émotions, qui sont beaucoup
plus puissants que la logique pure
dans les processus d’apprentissage,
au grand désespoir des chercheurs.
Raconter la science,
c’est utiliser volontairement
un registre de communication simplifié.
Mais plus large, donc, plus riche,
pour habiller des concepts abstraits avec
des idées et des mots de tous les jours.
Les rendre plus familiers,
plus accessibles
pour donner envie d’apprendre,
de comprendre,
pour étonner, pour inspirer.
Raconter la science,
c’est prendre une page de savoir
et en faire une cocotte ou un avion,
une grenouille, un chapeau chinois.
C’est prendre la science
et lui donner une forme
pour lui donner du sens
et l’offrir au plus grand nombre.
(Applaudissements)
Parce que comme le disait
un grand journaliste scientifique,
personne ne vous reprochera jamais
d’avoir rendu quelque chose
trop facile à comprendre.
Personne,
sauf peut-être les chercheurs.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.